ALAN SEALES: Hey, guys.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
ALAN SEALES: So thanks
for coming.
This is hopefully one of many
performances of Broadway at
Google Talks.
Thank you.
We are fortunate enough to
have some of the cast and
creative from "Rodgers &
Hammerstein's Cinderella" with
us here today.
AUDIENCE: Woo!
ALAN SEALES: Yay!
So we are ready to get started
with two numbers, and then
we're going to go into Q&A. And
there'll be microphones
set up on either side.
So this is being recorded.
Make sure you use the
microphones for your questions.
We'll give you swag to reward
you, and it'll be fun.
And that'll be that.
So first--
Cinderella, I know.
So first off, recently on
Broadway as Sister Mary Robert
in "Sister Act," she has
appeared on Broadway in "South
Pacific" and on the first
national tour of "The Drowsy
Chaperone." Also, regional
theater productions include
"25th Annual Putnam County
Spelling Bee," "Wild Party,"
and "Songs for a New World,"
Marla Mindelle.
Come on.
That's only half
of your resume.
And we also have--
she originated the role of
Christmas Eve in "Avenue Q" on
Broadway and appeared in the
original London cast of the
same musical.
Other Broadway appearances
including "9 to 5," "Madame
Thenardier," and the revival
of "Les Miz" and "M.
Butterfly" and has also recently
played Linda, the
stage manager of "Bombshell"
on the TV series
"Smash." Ann Harada.
She won the 2002 Tony and Drama
Desk Award for featured
actress in musical in her
performance in "Thoroughly
Modern Millie." Other Broadway
credits include "Present
Laughter," "Cry Baby," "Old
Acquaintance," and "The Man
Who Came to Dinner," and known
to TV audiences for her
memorable roles on "Frasier"
and "Desperate Housewives,"
Harriet Harris.
Welcome.
And then lastly but not leastly
for this introductory
set, nominated for a Tony
Award for her current
performance as Cinderella and
her performance in Frank
Wildhorns' "Bonnie and Clyde."
She also starred as Nellie
Forbush in "South Pacific" and
appeared in the recent revival
of "Anything Goes." She made her
Broadway debut as Sandy in
"Grease," having won NBC's
reality competition, "Grease--
You're the One that I
Want!" Laura Osnes.
[MUSIC - "WHEN YOU'RE DRIVING
THROUGH THE MOONLIGHT"]
LAURA OSNES: And I
can imagine it.
MARLA MINDELLE: I
imagine it too.
ANN HARADA: I can imagine it,
and I have no imagination.
HARRIET HARRIS: I'm throwing
caution to the wind.
I am imagining it as well.
LAURA OSNES: Oh, I imagine
what that girl would be
feeling when dancing
with the prince.
[MUSIC - "A LOVELY NIGHT"]
HARRIET HARRIS: Charlotte!
ANN HARADA: Huh?
HARRIET HARRIS: Play
the pianoforte.
MARLA MINDELLE: Oh,
yes, Charlotte.
Please do.
ANN HARADA: OK, but it's
not gonna be good.
[MUSIC - "A LOVELY NIGHT"]
ALAN SEALES: Joining us now,
Tony Award-nominated for his
performance as the prince, his
Broadway credits include "The
Importance of Being Earnest,"
"Brighton Beach Memoirs," for
which he received a 2010 Drama
Desk Award, "Billy Elliot the
Musical," and the 2007 revival
of "Sunday in the Park with
George," Sontino Fantana.
Where are you?
There you are.
LAURA OSNES: Where's
your name tag?
SANTINO FONTANA:
I took it off.
I'm a rebel.
Don't arrest me.
LAURA OSNES: Santino Fontana.
[MUSIC - "TEN MINUTES AGO"]
LAURA OSNES: Thank you.
ALAN SEALES: Thank you, guys.
All right, let's give them
another round of applause.
Come back up on the stage.
And then lastly, part of
the creative side.
He is the president and
executive director of the
Rodgers & Hammerstein,
an Imagem Company.
Did I say that right?
All right.
He serves on several boards,
including Goodspeed Musical
and New Music USA and New York
City Center, and has served as
a Tony Awards nominator for two
seasons and is currently a
member of the Tony
Administration Committee.
Ted Chapin.
Hi, guys.
LAURA OSNES: Hey.
ALAN SEALES: So sorry about
the name, Santino.
SANTINO FONTANA: Oh, please.
I've been called much worse.
ALAN SEALES: Thank you.
SANTINO FONTANA: Anytime.
ALAN SEALES: I butchered
his last name.
You guys don't know that,
but I called it out.
SANTINO FONTANA: It's fine.
ALAN SEALES: Good.
So I guess let's start at the
very beginning, a very good
place to start.
LAURA OSNES: [SINGING]
A very good place to start.
ALAN SEALES: Thank you.
So, "Cinderella," of course, was
commissioned by CBS to be
produced for TV back in
1957, broadcast live
on March 31, 1957.
Surrounding all of that, there's
a lot of reasoning, I
guess, why it was brought back
or what brought it to Broadway
in the first place.
So Ted, you were kind of the
inspiration behind getting it
from there to here.
TED CHAPIN: Well, do we just--
ALAN SEALES: No, we're
recording, so we need a mic.
Yeah, let's get a
mic down here.
TED CHAPIN: I mean, part
of the fun of my job--
aside from hearing spontaneous
performances of songs from
other Rodgers & Hammerstein
shows, like "start at the very
beginning"--
the Rodgers & Hammerstein
catalog is an extraordinary
collection of musicals, as
you, I hope, all know.
But there's always a creative
side that you never can tell
where it's going to
happen and how.
One of the lead producers of
"Cinderella" is Robyn Goodman,
and she and I happened to be
on a trip that a Broadway
producer named Manny Azenberg
does to Israel every year.
And it's basically a trip for
people, wisenheimers who work
in the theater to see this part
of the world, just to see
this part of the world.
And since my mother's family
came over on the "Mayflower,"
I kept saying to Manny,
why are you asking
me about this trip?
It doesn't make any sense.
So the only way to shut
him up was to go.
So I went on a trip about five
years ago, and Robyn Goodman
was on the trip, and
we just hit it off.
And she said to me at one point,
gee, we're having such
a good time together.
Is there something
we could work on?
And I said, you know, no one's
ever actually thought about or
figured out how to take the
television version of
"Cinderella" that Rodgers &
Hammerstein wrote and adapt it
to a Broadway show.
So what about that?
And she started to think, oh,
wouldn't it be great to make a
modern Cinderella who stands up
for herself a little more?
So basically, that's
where it started.
And just over the years,
just one good idea
after another happened.
And so here we are with all of
these people doing incredible
honor to this show.
ALAN SEALES: Nice.
So talk about, I guess, from
the audition side of things
from the very beginning,
I guess--
and I'm not making
the pun again.
You start with a script, and
you go through revisions.
And you need to find a
bookwriter, and you go through
table readings and find
people to do so.
And how did you find
these people?
TED CHAPIN: Well, in the good
old days of Broadway, you
would write a script and take
it out of town and do it in
Boston or Philadelphia or
Washington or a couple of
those places and listen to those
audiences and make the
adjustments and then
come into town.
That's pretty prohibitively
expensive these days.
So the thing that Robyn and
her compadre Jill Furman,
who's here, were very smart
about is starting with a very
simple reading.
There are all these
things available--
readings, workshops--
and they kind of used every
version of it to get the
project to the next step.
The very first reading, which
is very informal, and
Laura was in it.
And I remember my comment
about it.
It was very funny and very
good, but they didn't, I
think, pay enough attention
to the music.
So I just said to Robyn, you
can't really do this without
paying attention to both the
music that exists and whatever
new music's going to
be put in there.
Because if it's somebody like
Douglas Carter Beane, who has
a very modern, edgy sense of
humor and sensibility, if
that's going to match with the
kind of romance of what
Rodgers & Hammerstein
wrote, that's
going to be very tricky.
And I think that was the
biggest challenge.
And I have to say that this team
really honed that right
up to opening night, how to make
certain that the humor is
right for the songs and the
songs come out of the story.
And I have to say of all the
shows I've worked on in my
days at R&H, this was
among the more,
first of all, joyous.
Sure, there were the
ups and downs.
There always are.
But it was a really, really
joyous, positive experience.
And just going backstage,
they're seeming to
have a very good time.
Either you're really, really
good actors, or you really are
having a good time.
ALAN SEALES: So Laura, you were
involved from the book
reading at the beginning,
right?
LAURA OSNES: Yes.
That one he was talking about
was literally an afternoon
where we got together and
literally read it out loud one
time through.
It was a very quick thing.
And then it was about six
months of we didn't hear
anything, or eight months
or whatever it was.
And then our first reading with
all of these folks was
January of 2012, so a
year and a half ago.
And we did a workshop last
summer, a four-week-long
workshop where we pretty much
staged the whole thing in a
rehearsal studio with framework
sets and even
choreographed numbers and were
memorized and all of that.
And then did another reading
last October of 2012, and then
we started rehearsal
in December.
So it's been really exciting to
see the changes in the show
and how it's developed
over time.
But I have to say, I think the
brunt of the changes came
during previews on Broadway.
Even though we had a year to
kind of prepare and shift
things and make it better and
better, I feel like most of
the changes happened once we
had a real audience and we
were getting real feedback
from real people who were
going to come see the show.
ALAN SEALES: So for those who
don't know, what are previews?
LAURA OSNES: Previews is the
month-long period before a
show officially opens on
Broadway, and every Broadway
show has as a season
of previews.
So we had about 41
performances-- it's usually
about a month long--
where we're still rehearsing
during the day and performing
every night.
SANTINO FONTANA:
It's like beta.
I know my audience.
LAURA OSNES: There we go.
So yeah, we're still making
changes every day.
We're rehearsing.
We're getting new script changes
based on how the
previous night's audience
responded.
So if jokes aren't getting
laughs three nights in a row,
maybe that joke gets cut, or
maybe it gets changed.
Or if a song isn't working,
maybe the song either gets cut
or shifted or things
like that.
So during previews, the show
is constantly changing.
And then just a few days before
previews, we freeze the
show for opening night.
And from opening night on,
it's just the same show.
ALAN SEALES: So, Marla, maybe
you can speak to this.
Is there anything major that
ever does get cut from shows?
MARLA MINDELLE: Womp womp.
ALAN SEALES: Leading question.
MARLA MINDELLE: Yes.
My character and another
character, I think, took a lot
of the brunt of the changes,
because our characters are
different than the
originally-conceived story as
we all know.
There are two evil stepsisters
usually.
And in this version, I'm
actually very nice and very
shy, and I have a crush
on somebody else
who is not the prince.
He is a revolutionary is
named Jean Michel.
And so him and I have this plot
B love story going on.
And we had this lovely little
duet that just wasn't working,
and so that got cut maybe
two weeks into previews.
And so, I'm not going to lie,
it was a little bit sad,
because you work on something
for so long, and it becomes
second nature.
And it was a nice little moment,
but in the grand
scheme of the show, it
just wasn't working.
So it had to go.
But for those two weeks, we
had a great time on stage
together singing and dancing
our little number.
And
Also, Harriet, Ann, and I had a
number in the first act that
was also cut about
two weeks in.
So yeah, it was tricky.
But life goes on, and we
still have a good time.
ALAN SEALES: Incidentally,
let's see what we have
in the goody bag.
What's this, programs?
We've got some programs here.
These are your incentives for
getting up at the microphones
and asking questions.
So we've got some of that.
And then what else is in here?
CDs of the score, which is all
these guys singing, which is
available--
I wrote it down so I don't
get it wrong--
on iTunes--
I can remember that-- and
Ghostlight Records.
So there you go.
Ask some questions.
Get some stuff.
Harriet, what is it like working
with Ann and Marla?
I've seen the show, right.
And typically, like Marla said,
the stepsisters are
altogether evil and with the
stepmama, and they're always
trying to do bad things
to everyone.
But now, it's like Marla's
off on her own thing,
doing her own thing.
How do you balance
that on stage?
HARRIET HARRIS: I think the
mother has goals for these
girls, so she's unaware to some
extent, like a lot of
mothers are, that the children
are growing up and
going their own way.
And she has a vision for what
would make a better life for
these girls.
And in her world, the only
way to have a good life--
she's not a very
modern woman--
the only way to have
a good life is to
marry a man with money.
And in that world in which she
grew up, that's how you do it.
And she doesn't see how her
girls can live without that.
I think she feels either Marla
is the eldest and should marry
first, because that's the
way it used to be.
Or maybe perhaps she knows
what the prince likes, so
she's going to push Marla.
If Ann were the one that the
prince would like, I'd push
Ann in hopes that then Marla
would get a good husband.
But it's all about
that for her.
So she doesn't see that there's
a romance developing
with a very young, poor
revolutionary, because who
would choose that, frankly?
So in her world, who
would do that?
So I think that's a lot of it.
There's a blind spot that she
has about her kids in
assuming, like a lot of parents
do, you will to join
the family business.
You will want to live
the life I've lived.
You will learn by
my experience.
The song that we had that was
cut was about "learn from my
experience." I married
for love.
It doesn't work out.
You need stability.
You need this, and the way
to get it in this world
is you get a man.
So that's what her goals are
for the daughters, and it's
fun to work with the two.
As actresses, they're really
fun to work with.
MARLA MINDELLE: We're
just divas.
Just three divas.
HARRIET HARRIS: They're
really adorable.
LAURA OSNES: We've been around
either so much that we
coordinating our outfits.
Without even calling
each other, we
all showed up matching.
HARRIET HARRIS: And Laura too.
Because we're almost always
all together, it's a very
peculiar little family
dynamic.
And we're always adversarial,
even if people are maybe
passively supportive of Laura
in the household.
She's the brunt of so many
things and of so much bad
behavior on my part, anyway.
But it's wonderfully strung
together, and it is different
than just the normal
"Cinderella."
ALAN SEALES: So, Santino,
do feel left out?
Are you lonely?
SANTINO FONTANA:
No, not at all.
I feel great.
ALAN SEALES: You have your
band of merry men.
SANTINO FONTANA: I do.
I originally didn't have any
interest in being in
"Cinderella" or playing the
prince, because we don't
typically know anything
about the prince.
We know nothing about his
personality or anything.
And then when I got the script,
which Douglas Carter
Beane had written after Ted and
Robyn got together, his
very first line--
I can say that, right?
Should I not say that?
I can say that.
So the very first line in the
very original script-- it's
slightly changed--
he slays a giant,
first of all.
And then on top of the giant,
he says, "I just wish I was
doing something more important
with my life." And I laughed,
and I was like, OK,
this is great.
So he also has no parents.
His parents passed away, and
he's kind of rudderless and
trying to figure out who should
I be and how should I
be and how can I
be a good king.
And he also is very empathic,
and he worries about the
people of his kingdom.
And he is, actually, fairly
alone through the play.
There's a great actor, Peter
Bartlett, who plays kind of
his advisor.
And he's corrupt and trying to
get power for himself, and I
discover that through
the show.
But that's already so much
more complex than
what we're used to.
But I also think with a modern
audience, you don't want to
root for the girl to fall
in love with a guy
we don't know now.
We're like, oh, yes,
he's tall.
Go.
That's not enough anymore.
You're like, he may abuse you.
We don't know anything
about him.
Or he could be too
stupid for you.
So I think what's great is kind
of embracing that, and
that what makes somebody
charming is less to do with
what they look like and more
to do with what they do.
ALAN SEALES: You have a name.
You're not Prince Charming.
SANTINO FONTANA: Exactly.
His name is Topher.
He chose that.
It's Christopher, actually.
LAURA OSNES: Short
for Christopher.
SANTINO FONTANA: Short
ALAN SEALES: "Chris-topher."
SANTINO FONTANA: Yeah,
so there you go.
Yeah, but it's a great time.
I'm off stage like half the
show, and people always, I
think, think I'm on stage
more, because I'm always
talked about.
Because as Harriet explained,
in this world, the prince is
looking for a wife, and so
that's the quickest way to get
something to happen.
ALAN SEALES: Cool.
So I want to go back to the
audition process, because the
whole behind the scenes aspect
of all of this always has
intrigued me and always
has interested me.
Each of you--
take turns, I guess--
when did you get involved?
And at what point where
you like, yup,
this is my next role.
I want to do this.
This is great.
Show me the money.
ANN HARADA: This is a very
boring answer for this
particular show, because we
were all called and said,
would you like to do a reading
of "Cinderella?" And I said,
yes, I would.
So we showed up in January of
2012, and we worked for a week
together, and we
did a reading.
LAURA OSNES: All of us.
ANN HARADA: All of us.
And that was it.
We never auditioned.
That was it.
It was like, we like you.
OK, thanks, that was awesome.
And I went home, and I thought,
if this actually
comes to Broadway, this will
be my next Broadway show.
But I don't know if it's going
to come to Broadway.
Because we are always involved
in readings and things where
they say, we are on a fast
track to Broadway, and it
never happens.
I mean, I'm sure we all have
many, many shows we could say
that about.
So it was thrilling to be a
part of that idea, and the
idea that somebody had actually
handpicked us and
said, we think you'd be right
for these roles is fantastic.
But we didn't audition.
ALAN SEALES: How much of the
score did you know beforehand,
all of you?
ANN HARADA: All.
SANTINO FONTANA: I didn't.
I didn't.
The play I was doing before
this, Robyn Goodman, the
producer, also produced
that play.
And when she gave me the script,
I was humming "Ten
Minutes Ago." That's the
only song I've really
knew knew from it.
So I was pretty new to it.
But you knew all of it.
LAURA OSNES: No.
I knew "In My Own Little
Corner." I had sung that song,
which is Cinderella's kind
of "I want" song.
her first song in the show.
And I had learned it in voice
lessons when I was
like 10 years old.
And I remember being familiar
with "Ten Minutes Ago" and
familiar with some of the other
songs, but only because
I had heard them somewhere in my
psyche of growing up, which
is true of many Rodgers
& Hammerstein songs.
I did not grow up watching
the movie.
I still have not seen it.
I saw the Brandy version
once in like 1994 or
whenever it came out.
But that's kind of it.
So I was familiar.
SANTINO FONTANA: Why do you say
the Brandy version and not
the Whitney Houston version?
LAURA OSNES: Because Brandy
played Cinderella.
ANN HARADA: Brandy played
Cinderella.
SANTINO FONTANA: I know, but
it's Whitney Houston.
LAURA OSNES: Whitney
produced it.
ANN HARADA: But have
you seen it?
SANTINO FONTANA: Bobby!
Bobby!
Love it.
Yes, I've seen it.
ANN HARADA: Well, it's
not really her movie.
SANTINO FONTANA: But it's
Whitney Houston.
ANN HARADA: But it's
Brandy's movie.
SANTINO FONTANA: Whatever.
LAURA OSNES: It's called
"Cinderella."
SANTINO FONTANA: I feel bad
for her, that's all.
ALAN SEALES: Generalizng,
backing up.
Are there any auditions in your
past in your career that
you have gone into,
and you're like.
God, I screwed this up?
SANTINO FONTANA: We've
never auditioned.
None of us.
We've never auditioned.
We're offer only.
That's all of us.
HARRIET HARRIS: And it
always works out.
SANTINO FONTANA: Like yesterday,
I had a callback
for something in the morning
in Brooklyn by the
water at 11:00 AM.
And I was like, what the
hell am I doing here?
ALAN SEALES: 11:00
AM is early?
SANTINO FONTANA: Yes.
MARLA MINDELLE: That's
like 6:00 AM.
SANTINO FONTANA: I get
done at 11:00 PM.
We get out of the
show at 10:30.
You go home at 11:00.
Then you eat.
You go to sleep at 2:00 or
whatever, if you go to sleep.
She goes a lot of bars.
I'm kidding.
She doesn't drink.
ALAN SEALES: Water.
SANTINO FONTANA: No.
What I'm saying is that
happens all the time.
Yes, constantly.
Constantly.
It's like a job interview
constantly.
You're constantly on
a job interview.
We were just talking about
what's so lovely here--
we had a tour of the building.
And it seems like
such a safe--
I'm sure you all have opinions
about that as well-- but it
seems, from our point of view,
there's so many things here to
support you.
So you're trying something
new, and if it fails and
you're moving toward something
but you keep having small
failures along the way, you have
the security of knowing I
can come back tomorrow and play
pool over there and then
go over there.
We are in our apartments alone
with a piece of paper, and
we're trying to make
that piece of paper
come to life alone.
And then it's on us to go into
a room and create a reality
that doesn't exist for somebody
on another side of a
table who has to judge that.
And that's constant.
So that kind of job interview
process is something that's
very normal to us and something
we're very used to.
ALAN SEALES: So life
of an actor.
You just described the awesome
sauce that makes auditions.
Talking about, I guess,
wider picture still.
Backing up, as a young,
strapping lad, you said, I'm
going to grow up, and I'm
going to be on stage.
What made you want to do that?
All of you, when did you
decide, this is for me?
I want to struggle
and possibly wait
tables my whole life.
SANTINO FONTANA: You know,
everyone says that.
I never felt like--
MARLA MINDELLE: Waited tables?
SANTINO FONTANA: I never felt
like, I want to struggle.
I mean, now in hindsight, I
can say, yeah, whoa, I was
struggling in that point.
But while I was in it, I'd
never felt like it was.
Someone asked us the other day,
when did you decide to
sacrifice so many
things for this?
And it never felt like
a sacrifice,
because it's what I love.
I wanted to be a baseball player
in high school, and it
was between baseball and this.
And the funny thing is there's a
girl from my high school who
works at Google, Kelly Wilde.
She's on vacation.
Bitch.
Kidding.
I'm kidding.
I love her.
But I remember thinking when
I finally was like, no, I'm
better at this, and it brings
more joy than anything else,
then there is no sacrifice,
and there is no struggle.
It's just what you do.
ALAN SEALES: And the rest of
you have similar stories?
MARLA MINDELLE: From
the womb I wanted
to perform and struggle.
My father wrote music and so my
mother, when I was inside
her belly, would be
playing "Evita"
and all these musicals.
And I really think that I was
genetically programmed to pop
out and want to do this for
a living, because I was
surrounded by it 24/7.
And I got into basketball.
I was a sports person.
But then in high school,
I was just like, I just
gotta pursue this.
And so I went to college for
it, and then got lucky, and
here I am with these
fine people.
ALAN SEALES: So Harriet and
Ann, you guys have some TV
experience as well.
Waking up in the morning,
do you choose theater?
Do you choose TV?
Which one-- you're giving me
a funny look over there.
HARRIET HARRIS: Well, right
now, I'm choosing theater.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
If you could pick one to do--
HARRIET HARRIS: I wouldn't
want to do that.
ALAN SEALES: TV?
HARRIET HARRIS: No,
at this point, I
wouldn't want to do it.
I like change.
It's like working on
different projects.
It is a very different
thing to do.
And for the first--
Oh, God, I've been an
actress so long--
and that was part of it.
And you get better and better
and better usually as you do
it, and you start to think,
I know how to do that.
The thing that used to be such
a challenge isn't a challenge
anymore, and I have to figure
out how to do something else,
because I know how to do this.
I can break down a scene.
I know what the story is.
I know how to tell the story.
I know how to do the jokes.
And there were so many things
that I just thought, you could
get carpal tunnel syndrome from
being an actor if you
don't do a lot of different
kinds of things.
So I went with a play out to
California, and suddenly there
was an opportunity to start
doing television, and I didn't
know how to do it.
And I thought, this is great.
I used some of the same tools.
I'm pursuing the same
sorts of things.
But I had to learn how to use
them differently, and I have
to grab different tools from
the box that I didn't even
know those tools were
in that box.
So I liked that.
And then I got sort of
proficient at that, and I
thought, oh, I really don't know
anything about musicals.
And somebody asked me to do a
musical, and I went, oh, that
will be really exciting to do.
So that, I think, is important
to keep doing different things
and challenging oneself.
And to say, I'm only doing this
from now, I don't think
I'd like to do that.
ALAN SEALES: OK.
So there's certain things of
each that you like more at
different times.
HARRIET HARRIS: Oh, yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
I mean, what's the big
difference though?
HARRIET HARRIS: It's the
difference between, say,
talking to your best friend
and yelling at them and
whispering to them.
It's the same relationship, the
same overall relationship,
and a different way of
expressing oneself.
And I think that you want
both of those things.
In a real relationship, maybe
you don't spend most of your
time talking to your best friend
whispering or shouting.
But that exists, and so it's
nice to have that spectrum.
ALAN SEALES: Is there a
question over here?
I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
First, I just want to
say you guys are
all absolutely amazing.
I haven't gotten a chance to see
the performance yet, but
I'm very excited.
I'm going to go out and buy
my tickets after this.
ANN HARADA: Yay!
AUDIENCE: I actually grew
up watching the original
original, not the
Brandy version.
And my question is, I'm actually
a bit of a purist.
I find that I love the
originals, and I find myself
going back to them
over and over.
I liked the Brandy one, but the
original was my favorite.
Have you felt that there's
been any backlash or
unhappiness from people that
you've changed the story?
The characters are slightly
different, that you didn't
kind of stick to the original?
Not that I don't love this
version, but just curious.
SANTINO FONTANA: When you say
the original, was that the
Julie Andrews one or the
Lesley Ann Warren one?
AUDIENCE: The Lesley
Ann Warren one.
SANTINO FONTANA: So that was
actually the second one.
AUDIENCE: Oh, now this
is embarrassing
SANTINO FONTANA: No,
this is perfect.
And it's also hilarious to me
that you work at Google, which
is the most progressive
company in the world.
But there is actually
no original.
Perrault wrote a French fairy
tale which actually had three
balls, where they'd dance and
then she would run away.
And he'd be like, God, I wish
she could come back.
And then there would be second
ball, and then he'd be like,
God, I wish she could
come back.
And then the third ball,
she left her shoe.
So then we have somehow, with
the help of Disney and Rodgers
& Hammerstein, we've changed
that story as
time has moved on.
And so the original Julie
Andrews version, which was
shorter, actually, even than the
Lesley Ann Warren version,
they're both different scripts,
which is also
different from the Brandy
version, which has a Rodgers &
Hart song in it.
So it's truly a living thing.
It really doesn't have
an original.
That said, yes, there are people
who come expecting the
Disney cartoon and
are wondering why
the mice don't sing.
LAURA OSNES: And why
I'm not blonde.
SANTINO FONTANA: And why
she's not blonde.
And that's to say, hey, people
have strong emotional
reactions to all different forms
of art in all different
times, and we respect and
totally uphold that.
At the same time, our version
is just this version.
But every version, there isn't
actually an original.
That's kind of the biggest--
LAURA OSNES: Every time it's
done, it's been adjusted.
SANTINO FONTANA: It's been
adjusted every time.
I mean, so is "Hamlet." There's
quarto versions.
There's a second quarto.
I love when there's purists for
Shakespeare, and they're
like, why did you cut this
line from Act 2, scene 3?
And I'm like, well,
that's the quarto.
We're doing the folio.
So there's always a living,
breathing thing.
And I just love that,
because I love that
that's what we do--
something that's so alive
it can't stay still.
And if you try to trap
it, it won't work.
HARRIET HARRIS: But there
are people at the end.
They're usually people
lined up--
and it's very sweet.
Some of them are children.
Some of them are grown women
with crowns on--
that want to have their
playbills signed.
And sometimes people do say,
I love the show, but I'm
struggling with a couple
of things.
And you think, you're struggling
about "Cinderella"?
What must your life be like?
But there are a couple of things
in the show that are
significantly different, and
most people adore that.
And most people go, you know,
I really thought I knew it,
and I'm so thrilled that there's
a reason to come back
for the second act.
So the choices that were made, I
think, make it a little more
titillating for people
to come back again.
ANN HARADA: I personally,
personally guarantee that this
is as true in spirit to that
version that is in your head,
because there's no way I would
have done this show if I
thought it was in any way
disrespectful or untrue to
what the themes are in that.
I revere the R&H canon.
I've seen every movie, every
blah blah, every iteration of
the story so far.
And it's a new version, and yes,
some things might throw
you a little bit.
But I promise you, you will
feel the same feelings.
LAURA OSNES: That's it.
ANN HARADA: You'll feel
all the feelings.
SANTINO FONTANA: Yup.
TED CHAPIN: Can I have
a quick shot at that?
ALAN SEALES: We're running
short on time.
TED CHAPIN: I'm usually the one
who gets it in the neck
for having been impure about
things Rodgers & Hammerstein.
And so I like hearing this,
because the fact is it has
been changed every
time slightly.
But the thing I wanted to say is
one of the challenges when
you do something like this,
and you take what was
basically 70 minutes of material
in 1957 and make it
into a Broadway show, you have
to add to the score.
And I think the reason that the
two songs that you heard
about earlier that ended up not
being in is because you
don't a composer and lyricist
in the room to whom you can
say, could you change that
song a little bit?
You kind of have the song that
we have in the files to offer,
and both of those songs, they
did incredibly well.
The problem was not them.
The problem was the material,
and it just didn't really
support what the entire
rest of the show was.
And that's a challenge when
you do something like this
where you're taking the basics
of something from before and
adding to it.
I just wanted to say that.
ALAN SEALES: Over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I saw the show a couple weeks
ago, and I really loved it.
One of the things that really
impressed me about the show
was the costumes of the show,
and especially Cinderella and
Fairy Godmother had these huge
transformations where one
minute they were in
plainclothes, and the next
minute they were suddenly in
these giant ballgowns.
And I want to know
what was it like
working with those costumes?
Maybe more directed
toward Laura.
How easy was it to set up that
costume and then unleash it?
And just in general, how did
you guys manage such quick
costume changes?
Sometimes you'll bounce out, and
all of a sudden you're in
a completely new dress and
completely new hair.
And it just baffled me.
It was amazing.
LAURA OSNES: I'm so glad.
Has anyone else seen the show
here by raising hands?
A few people?
That's great.
The costume changes are really
amazingly, and William Ivey
Long, our customer designer,
won the Tony Award for his
costume design for our show.
And it's so rightly deserved,
because the design behind
these transformation costumes
is flawless.
It's absolutely amazing, and I
think revolutionary in the
world of theater
quick changes.
I have three transformations
in the show,
and they all happen--
unfortunately, I can't really
reveal any of the secrets to
you-- but they all happen
in front of your eyes.
We don't use any body doubles.
We don't do blackouts.
It's literally like
pull a thing--
ALAN SEALES: There's
no fog either.
LAURA OSNES: There's no fog.
It all happens, and everyone's
like, how did you do it?
And I'm like, if you watch,
you could know.
But it all happens so fast, and
the design behind it is
kind of foolproof.
I always tell people the very
first time I did the
transformations in the costume
shop with burlap fabric in the
pre-test versions,
they worked.
So it was a matter of finessing
it to make it look
natural and make it look like
it was happening to me as
opposed to me doing
it to myself.
I'm pretty much in charge of
my quick changes, which is
awesome and terrifying
at the same time.
But we haven't had any disasters
yet, and I always
love hearing the audience
reactions.
But it just took a
little finessing
and a little practice.
But the design behind it,
it's like snaps and
Velcro, which work.
We're not relying on technology
and things like that.
So it's pretty exciting.
ALAN SEALES: So we are right
at 2:45, if you've got to--
Ted's got a call with
Japan, I think.
You've got to go.
SANTINO FONTANA: If you
want, we could stay.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
Laura, you've got to
go too, right?
LAURA OSNES: I do,
unfortunately.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
ANN HARADA: But we'll stay.
SANTINO FONTANA: Suddenly,
there's lots
of interest in questions.
ALAN SEALES: Yes, yes.
LAURA OSNES: Thanks,
everybody.
ALAN SEALES: Yes, thank
you so much.
So if you are asking questions,
come see me
afterwards, and I'll give you
some swag, You've been waiting
for a while.
AUDIENCE: Actually, I was
thinking about having seen all
three incarnations, from the
Julie Andrews version to the
Lesley Ann Warren version
to this version.
The character has stayed the
same, but society has changed.
And it interests me what, I
guess, the bookwriter was told
in how to make it something
that's accessible to girls in
the 21st century as opposed to
girls just post-World War II.
But I guess there's nobody there
who can answer this.
SANTINO FONTANA: No,
that's Douglas.
At the core of Cinderella's
story is that somebody comes
from seemingly nothing
and has something.
And there's also romance tied
in there, that somebody is
needed on a personal level
with somebody else.
That's kind of the core story.
And I think Doug, he had
political stuff that he wanted
to play, because he wanted to
expand those characters.
And suddenly Jean Michel popped
into his head and
everybody's feelings
about that.
And also, I think he
dealt with the
prince as a human being.
If the prince is a prince,
a huge part of
his life is the kingdom.
So to not deal with it in those
other versions in any
political or social way is kind
of cutting the prince off
at the knees.
And so in engaging with that,
he suddenly had a bunch of
stuff to play with, I think.
ANN HARADA: And in terms of
Cinderella's change, I think
what Robyn felt and what Doug
felt was that Cinderella needs
to be able to help the prince
just as much as he helps her.
That they will be a marriage
of equals, not he
is elevating her.
Yes, of course, he is elevating
her socially and
economically, but that as
people, it's not just like,
you're super pretty in a white
dress, let's get married,
which is sort of the
undercurrent of all previous
versions of "Cinderella."
This is, oh, we have something
in common.
We share something.
I can talk to you.
I can't talk to anybody else.
Do you know what I mean?
There's that connection in this
version that we're trying
so hard for girls to see.
No, look.
See?
It's not just enough he's
cute and he's rich.
You have to care about that
he's a good person, and he
cares that you're
a good person.
That's part of it.
SANTINO FONTANA: And thank God
that he did that, because I
think there are a lot of people
who do come up and say,
thank you so much for not making
my daughter want to
wear a tiara with the wish that
she'll meet some guy who
will just sweep her
off her feet and
everything will be fine.
But it goes farther.
ALAN SEALES: Over here?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I just wanted to say I think
you guys are amazing.
I saw the show also,
and it was great.
I'm going to deviate
from all the
Cinderella version questions.
And I know you guys were talking
about how 11:00 AM's
kind of early.
And for us here, 11:00
AM's kind of late.
I mean, it's not late.
People come in at 11:00 AM.
It's possible.
But I was just wondering,
I guess, what your
typical day is like.
I know sometimes you guys
have two-show days
versus one-show days.
What is it like to be living
the Broadway--
MARLA MINDELLE: The
Broadway dream?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
MARLA MINDELLE: Well, we have
eight shows a week, so Sunday
nights and Mondays
are our weekends.
And I always say, when you
guys are coming home from
work, we're always
going to work.
So we're on a completely
opposite schedule.
We end usually around
like 10:00 or 11:00.
And then you've got to wind
down, so then it's like 2:00
AM, and you're going to bed.
You're waking up at around
like 10:30 or 11:00.
That's early for us.
And then you either have another
show, or you have an
audition that you have
to prepare for, or
you go to the gym.
Your daytime is your
free time, but you
always have the show.
I mean, at least I do anyway.
It's always about getting to the
show and making sure that
I'm eating the right things
for the show.
That I have enough rest
That I feel well enough
to do the show.
Yeah.
Anyone else?
ANN HARADA: I have a kid,
so I get up early.
MARLA MINDELLE: How early?
ANN HARADA: Well, now that he's
older, it's really good,
because I can leave out a bowl
of cereal the night before and
tell him, your milk
is in the fridge.
Just get it out of the door, and
that buys me an extra 20
minutes in the morning
if he can do that.
Do you know what I mean?
But I still have to throw his
clothes at him and make sure
he brushes his teeth
and stuff.
And then I take him to camp or
school or whatever the heck it
is first thing in the morning
that children do.
And then I come home, and
I try to take a nap,
because I've died.
Because I'm on Marla's
schedule.
I can't just go right to
bed after the show.
I have to eat and unwind
and whatever.
And so it's 2 o'clock.
MARLA MINDELLE: Watch
reality TV.
SANTINO FONTANA: Talk
about yesterday.
Tell them about yesterday.
ANN HARADA: Oh.
So yesterday, we had an
appearance on the "Live with
Kelly and Michael Show," which
meant that me and some of the
other women in the ensemble
had to be at
the studio at 7:15.
AUDIENCE: In the morning.
ANN HARADA: AM.
MARLA MINDELLE: Which is
unacceptable for us.
ANN HARADA: It is
not a good time.
AUDIENCE: That's early
for us too.
ANN HARADA: Right, that would
be early for anybody.
And when they do "The Today
Show," it's like a 5:30 call.
SANTINO FONTANA: And
we had two shows.
ANN HARADA: Yes, then
So then we did that first thing
in the morning, and then
I went to the theater, tried
to take a little nap.
Then we had show one
at 2 o'clock.
Then we had show two at 7:30.
By the end of the day,
literally, I was dead, fried.
I had no concept of time.
I did not know where I was.
But that's sort of what it is.
You try to sleep when you can
sleep, and you have your life.
Everybody's the same.
We all have our things outside
of work that take up our time
that we need to get done and
then also do our jobs.
We, as actors, tend to push more
toward later in the day,
because that's when we work.
HARRIET HARRIS: But when
you get older, you
can't sleep that late.
So I wake up at 6:20,
and I stay quiet for
as much as I can.
I can't sleep past it.
And I read for a while.
I have birds, so I try to be
very quiet so the birds don't
wake up and I don't wake
up my sweetheart.
And then around 8:30, if they
aren't all awake, then they
have get up.
Because my day has to
begin at some point.
But it's a very difficult
schedule.
TV's a much easier schedule,
because I wake up early.
And in California, I wake up,
and I have a cup of coffee.
And I'm going out, and I'm
smashing aphids on my roses
and doing interesting things
that occupy my time.
In New York, I'm sitting in my
room, trying to turn the page
ever so quietly.
ALAN SEALES: Cool.
Yeah, over here?
AUDIENCE: OK, so side note--
I'm still mourning "Smash," and
I'm so excited so see this
other side of your
acting today.
ANN HARADA: You're so sweet.
AUDIENCE: Second of all, you're
all so casually talking
about auditioning.
And in the corporate world, it's
like, oh, I'm tiptoeing
out at lunch hour to
go on an interview.
So is it very normal for you
to just be auditioning for
other projects while you're
working on this?
SANTINO FONTANA: Well, they're
all different.
I mean, the audition I was
talking about the other day,
they're voiceovers.
I'm the voice of Excedrin.
"Headaches are where
Excedrin excels."
ALAN SEALES: That's you?
SANTINO FONTANA: Google
it, please.
Go buy some Excedrin.
It'll help me.
So that doesn't conflict, and
there are also things that
work around your schedule
that don't conflict.
And some things you audition
for, and they won't happen
until next year.
Or a writer wants to meet with
you because they have an idea
for a part that they're
looking to do in 2015.
So you can go out and do that.
I mean, we all know the nature
of theater is it
comes and it goes.
So you're always looking
forward.
MARLA MINDELLE: You're always
looking for the next job, even
when you have a job.
SANTINO FONTANA: Which doesn't
mean you're going to take the
other one either.
MARLA MINDELLE: Right.
SANTINO FONTANA: But you know.
HARRIET HARRIS: And we
have a contract.
We know how long the
contract is.
And we don't know if the show
extends beyond the contract if
that will impact on
our lives or not.
So you do have to keep an eye
towards the future, because
you can't depend on
anything, really.
Google's probably going
to be here tomorrow.
ANN HARADA: Show business,
not so much.
MARLA MINDELLE: "Cinderella"
will be too.
HARRIET HARRIS: Sure, but--
ALAN SEALES: I guess worst case,
knock on chair, that a
show unexpectedly gets canceled,
that ends your
contract early, and you
have no control.
ANN HARADA: Correct.
ALAN SEALES: So you've got to
be doing the next thing.
MARLA MINDELLE: We've
been very fortunate.
Who doesn't love Cinderella?
Who doesn't want to
come see the show?
And every child wants their
family to take it, so our
ticket sales have been doing--
SANTINO FONTANA: Very well.
MARLA MINDELLE: Yeah.
Very, very well,
which is great.
Which means that we have
a job for at least--
well, we have what?
A year contract?
ANN HARADA: Mm hmm.
MARLA MINDELLE: So we started
in January, which means that
this January, our contract
will be up.
And we can choose to re-sign
or we can choose to end the
contract and look for
the next thing.
ANN HARADA: Or they
could get fire us.
SANTINO FONTANA: Yeah.
MARLA MINDELLE: Or
we can get fired.
I don't think that's
going happen.
I hope not.
ALAN SEALES: Over here?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
OK, my question is
kind of cliche.
But if you could give one piece
of advice to people who
want to do this for a living,
what would it be?
ALAN SEALES: She's a visitor.
She's not a Googler.
I looked.
SANTINO FONTANA: I
was gonna say.
MARLA MINDELLE: Going
on secret job
interviews/auditions?
Oh, gosh, we all have
such different,
different pieces of advice.
I always talk about going
to a good college.
But if you haven't gone to
a good college, oof.
Well, you know what I mean.
Like if you went for
accounting--
SANTINO FONTANA: And
just it's over.
Just kill the dream.
ALAN SEALES: Let me see if
I can lead you guys here.
In my experience--
I used to perform to as
well, and that's why I
breathe them in--
the people I see succeed over
those who don't are those who
know how to market themselves.
MARLA MINDELLE: Interesting.
ANN HARADA: I don't see
it that way at all.
SANTINO FONTANA: I have
to say, I am a
terrible marketer of myself.
ANN HARADA: He sucks.
SANTINO FONTANA: I'm terrible.
I'd rather be like,
I'm two steps away
from a homeless person.
Just put me in a corner
with some food.
Just leave me alone.
I'm a terrible marketer
of myself.
I understand your commenting
that you
feel like it's cliche.
The answer is somewhat
cliche, sadly.
First of all, you've just got
to do it, and the operative
word there is "do." So if you
want to be an actor, you've
got to be acting.
And that doesn't mean
necessarily on Broadway.
That means in a class.
Because identifying what you
want to do is, first of all,
honing in on what that really
specifically means.
I was talking to a student who
asked, I want to do what
you're doing.
How do I do that?
And I was like, well, what
do you want to do?
I want to be an actor.
So you want to tell stories
as characters?
Yes.
What kind of stories?
Well, musicals.
OK, well, that's very different
than if you want to
go be in movies or television
or if you want to be in
straight plays.
If you want to do classical
theater, you need another
understanding.
You need to be able
to do verse.
There's so many skills that
are potentially required.
First, what is most important is
to identify what skills do
you need to go after.
Because what do you
really want to do?
What speaks to you?
And that's easy, because you
can go out and find that.
And it's a process.
My biggest advice really would
be to take any sense of
pressure off of your
shoulders.
Morgan Freeman was 40 when
he made his first movie.
James Gandolfini, who just
passed, he didn't come to
acting until after college.
There's no rush.
There's 8 million ways to
skin that cat, but you
have to go after it.
And you can do that while you're
doing other things.
ALAN SEALES: If you guys could
do any role from any time
ever, what would you do?
MARLA MINDELLE: You
mean Broadway?
ALAN SEALES: Anything, Well,
yeah, let's stick to Broadway.
Let's focus this.
We'll say Broadway.
MARLA MINDELLE: These are such
hard-hitting questions.
ALAN SEALES: Let's get to the
meat of the situation, Marla.
MARLA MINDELLE: Oh, gosh.
Evita.
I've always wanted
to be Elphaba--
just for one week though,
because it seems too hard to
do for longer than a week.
ALAN SEALES: Elphaba
from "Wicked."
MARLA MINDELLE: From "Wicked,"
yes, yes, yes.
From the Broadway musical
"Wicked." I've wanted to play
Ann Harada in "Smash"
at one point.
ALAN SEALES: That want one of
my questions, if you could
trade with somebody to do
one of their roles.
MARLA MINDELLE: Oh, definitely
Ann Harada.
Definitely.
She's so disgusted.
ANN HARADA: I don't know.
I feel like there's some great
roles out there that I don't
think I personally have the
chops to play, so I wouldn't
pick those.
I'd like to play Dolly in
"Hello, Dolly!" I'd like to
play Mrs. Lovett.
Harriet has played
Mrs. Lovett.
I'm very jealous of her.
I think every musical theater
actress thinks about playing
Rose in "Gypsy," at least
people of the character
persuasion do.
Things like that.
Those are, to me, mountains
that would be
great to climb someday.
But I want to go back to the
previous question about
marketing yourself.
It doesn't matter.
You don't need that.
You need to get out there, do
stuff with people, do stuff
with your friends.
I sort of feel like
that's the way.
Because only once you start
working with people, they'll
think of you for
the next thing.
And it all sort of snowballs.
You don't all have to play
in the same field.
I don't need to be
a movie star.
I don't need to be a TV star.
I like acting for
acting's sake.
I'm happy to be in a little box
in the East Village, and
I'm happy on Broadway.
Do you know what I mean?
So to me, it's all the same.
You're performing, and
you're trying to
bring truth to something.
HARRIET HARRIS: And I think
one of the things that
distinguishes actors is why
they want to be an actor.
Some people just think, because
I want to perform.
I want to entertain.
Or some people say, because I
love that sensation of all
that attention.
I like all eyes on the
high board and
being on the high board.
I don't mean that.
I like to tell a story.
I like to relate to people.
I'm a little usually of scared
people, unless it's a
situation like this,
where you're really
far away from me.
But it's a great way for me to
communicate ideas that are
usually formulated
in a much more
succinct way than I think.
So it's a chance to engage
and educate and say
this exists in life.
And it's a safe way for you to
look at it, and it's a safe
way for us to talk about it.
And it's challenging
at the same time.
So people are actors for all
sorts of different reasons.
But you really have to, I think,
devote yourself to what
you expect to get out of it.
And I think that what Ann was
talking about it being just as
credible anyplace.
It's true.
It doesn't matter.
Actors generally feel successful
if they're acting.
And you don't have to make a lot
of money unless your goal
is to make money, and then you
really shouldn't be an actor.
You should really be something
else if that's what you need.
And really, if you really need a
lot of attention, you should
be something else.
And I'm not saying you, but
I mean, one should.
The more you can define what you
expect for it to bring you
or want to contribute to it
more, like Santino was talking
about, the more you can define
that, the happier you probably
will be and the happier
you are as an actor.
You'll have more longevity,
I think.
ALAN SEALES: Nice.
Yes, next question.
AUDIENCE: Hi, guys.
I saw the play and I loved it,
so it's really fun to see you
all in person.
My question is if you have any
embarrassing onstage moments
from either "Cinderella" or a
previous role that you'd want
to share with us.
MARLA MINDELLE: It's an
ongoing embarrassment.
SANTINO FONTANA:
Tell the story.
Yesterday.
HARRIET HARRIS: Yesterday?
SANTINO FONTANA: Yeah.
HARRIET HARRIS: All right.
We're approaching
our 200th show.
I really love the show, and I
really love everybody in it.
And possibly I'm sleep deprived,
I don't know.
But I got to a certain point
in the afternoon and, of
course, I just couldn't think
of the next word.
And this does happen.
It starts happening in your
40s, and it continues.
So I say, "Oh, isn't it
wonderful how the needy just
keep on going?" So I had said,
"Isn't it wonderful how the
needy just keep on moving?"
So I thought, OK,
that was bad.
And then I look over,
and Marla's like--
Because Marla's so young,
she doesn't
make mistakes on stage.
MARLA MINDELLE: Not
true, not true.
HARRIET HARRIS: And Ann is
like, oh, how bad is this
going to get?
This could get really bad.
Harriet's got more
lines to go.
So anyway, in the evening I
thought, I am tired, but I'm
not going to make that
mistake again.
So I got to, "Isn't it wonderful
how the needy just
keep on--" I couldn't remember
"going." I couldn't remember
"moving." I just, what is
something like that?
So it started guess to sound
like a Katharine Hepburn
impersonation.
"Isn't it wonderful how the
needy just keep on--"
And I thought, I'm going to say
"keep on trucking." I know
it's going to come out, and
it's going be like some R.
Crumb cartoon where this
guy is going across.
But I didn't.
And finally, I came up with
"moving" again, and both Ann
and Marla sort of looked--
MARLA MINDELLE: I always
look at her.
I always smile at her
afterwards, because I want to
see her break or see if she'll
giggle or something.
So the next line she said
completely up to the ceiling,
because she didn't want to
make eye contact with us,
which then made me
laugh even more.
HARRIET HARRIS: And it just got
worse and worse, and I was
so overwhelmed about having
made that mistake.
And then I came back in.
In the next scene, I thought,
oh, completely recovered.
It's fine, fine.
A few scenes later, well, I run
in with this invitation.
And now the prince's is
not giving a ball,
he's giving a banquet.
And I run in, and I have
to shut the door.
And I ran, and I went, you
didn't shut the door.
You gotta go back and
shut the door.
So I go back and
And this is a line that I do all
on one breath, because it
just has to be that way for
there to be a response.
And so I go back,
and I'm running.
And the costume's like
40 pounds, so I'm
running, going back.
I'm running, shutting
the door.
And then I lose the invitation,
and the invitation
flutters out of my hand.
And I go over, and I'm so
awkward, because I've got this
huge hoop skirt on.
So I'm trying to get down, and
I can't get the invitation.
And then I thought I had it, and
I came up, and it's empty.
So I had to reach down again,
get the invitation.
MARLA MINDELLE: And I'm on stage
with her once again,
watching this entire thing.
HARRIET HARRIS: It was like my
life is flashing before me.
MARLA MINDELLE: But you
would never notice it.
And that's what I love about
it, is that it's so subtle.
And the only people that can
tell what's happening--
well, maybe not.
Maybe not just trying to get the
invitation off the floor.
HARRIET HARRIS: It was
a little awkward.
MARLA MINDELLE: But
the prior scene.
Like the "keep on moving."
No one would
tell, but we can tell.
And it's just a flicker of the
eye where you identify, oh,
that was a little
screw up there.
I caught you.
HARRIET HARRIS: Vicky has
gotten stuck in midair a
couple of times.
MARLA MINDELLE: Our
set has stopped.
HARRIET HARRIS: These
things are
accidents, or they're mistakes.
ALAN SEALES: The godmother,
Fairy Godmother.
MARLA MINDELLE: Yeah.
HARRIET HARRIS: But nothing
horrible really happens other
than humiliation.
SANTINO FONTANA: I fell.
I came in all my armor.
The very first scene, I come
in in all that armor.
And I step up on a tree log, and
I pose, and there's a big
light that hits me,
and trumpets play.
It was like, yay!
And I fell.
That happened yesterday, where
I was like, I'm now--
nope.
I just went down and
went back up again.
Oh, it's terrible, terrible.
ALAN SEALES: Next question.
Yeah, I think we're running
pretty close on time here.
AUDIENCE: Hi, two-part
question.
One is, what is each of your
favorite Broadway shows?
It doesn't have to be
one you've been in.
It could be one that
you've seen.
And then also, when you are
going and you're in the
audience seeing a show, you
probably experience it
differently than we would.
Are you thinking about what
they're doing backstage?
What sort of goes through
your mind?
MARLA MINDELLE: I do.
I think about that.
And also, it's a lot like high
school, because it's such a
small world.
I feel a lot of joy, because
we see all of
our friends on stage.
It's like we know somebody
in almost every show.
So yeah, it's a fun experience
for me, because I get to see
the people that I love
doing their thing.
That's me.
ALAN SEALES: What's your
favorite show?
MARLA MINDELLE: Oh, "Ghost
the Musical," which
only ran for like--
[APPLAUSE]
MARLA MINDELLE: Really?
AUDIENCE: Yes!
MARLA MINDELLE: Oh my god.
Everyone hated it.
I loved it.
I saw it four times.
I took him to see it.
ALAN SEALES: It was
an experience.
MARLA MINDELLE: It was an
experience, to say the least.
I loved it.
But also I love, of course,
"Gypsy": and "Sunday in the
Park with George." I'm a purist
at heart as well, even
though I loved "Ghost." But
I like a lot of the
old-fashioned ones as well.
That's what I was raised on.
So all of them?
I don't know.
HARRIET HARRIS: I guess my
favorite show I ever saw--
and I don't think that's really
true anymore, but it
may as well be true, because
it's the one that hit me most
viscerally--
was the "Sweeney Todd" that
Angela Lansbury and I saw Len
Cariou too do it.
And it was wonderful.
I loved that show.
But sometimes I go see things
now, and the things that I'm
most thrilled by is not what
the audience adores.
Because sometimes I just think
the audience expects so much
now, and they don't always
recognize that this incredible
little thing just happened.
And people don't know how
hard that incredible
little thing is.
And sometimes it's just two
actors talking to each other
for a few moments, and the
whole stage just seems to
vibrate and shimmer, because
they're so incredibly good.
And you just think, I hope that
everybody's getting that.
But it's not the thing
that people leap
up and go wow about.
And I kind of think, well, why
aren't we leaping up and going
wow about that stuff?
That to me is real artistry
and so beautiful.
So that's what I get excited
about most of the time, those
sort of times.
ANN HARADA: My favorite show
was also that production of
"Sweeney Todd" that I saw
the day it won the Tony.
And "Nicholas Nickleby," the
Royal Shakespeare Company's
four-hour version of "Nicholas
Nickleby."
Four and a half hours.
It was awesome.
I feel the same way.
I feel like we go to see shows,
and we are judging them
from a totally different
perspective almost.
And so for me, when I see
a particularly amazing
performance or a scene that
makes my heart go, oh, that
was perfect, that's what sort
of sticks in my head, as
opposed to that was
a really cool set.
I never think that.
SANTINO FONTANA: Funnily enough,
"Sweeney Todd" is also
my favorite show.
And I saw the videotape of the
tour of Angela Lansbury with
George Hearn back when
I was a kid.
Someone from my high school
showed it to me, and I thought
it was incredible.
So that.
And I think, yeah, we're
more critical.
But I think probably the biggest
difference is it's
just much more casual.
My parents come, and they're
like, oh, we've
got to go get dressed.
I'm like, no you don't.
I'll go wearing whatever.
It's just much more like, and
now we're going to see a play.
We're going to go.
I think that's probably the
biggest difference.
And to be honest, especially
when you're in a long-running
show like this, the last place
I want to be on my
day off is a theater.
So they're like, we've
got tickets.
I'm like, I don't want
to go to that.
I'm sure it's great.
MALE SPEAKER: One more.
One more, guys.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, we've
got one more question.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So my first comment
is for Santino.
I just wanted to say I'm looking
forward to the next
season of "Submissions Only."
SANTINO FONTANA: Oh, thanks.
AUDIENCE: And my question has
to do with the promo video,
and whose idea was it to
pair Sir Mix-a-Lot with
"Cindrella"?
SANTINO FONTANA: Oh,
that's right.
That was mine.
That was my idea.
"Submissions Only" is a web
series that basically got
started-- for the girl who
was asking about if
you want to do this--
a bunch of actors who weren't
working at the time.
She got a camera.
She wrote a script, and we just
started doing this show,
which kind of has had a great
following online.
And there's three seasons
now that we've shot.
The third season is
about to come out.
I had a lot of time in tech,
which is very slow and you're
working on one scene
at a time.
And they were doing lights, and
they're doing the set, and
they're doing costumes.
So you have a lot of time off.
And one of the taglines at the
beginning of the marketing of
"Cinderella" was "Glass slippers
or so back," which
they were hoping would both
combine the modern sensibility
that we have but also
the glass slippers.
And I was thinking of "Baby Got
Back." I was like, I don't
know why but glass slippers
are back.
It just got in my head, and I
was like, that'll be fun.
Let me play around with that.
So I wrote the lyrics to it,
and it's basically the same
idea, the same premise that
these people are obsessed with
this one body feature.
And in this play, everyone's
obsessed with these shoes,
these glass shoes.
So just keeping everybody's
kind of personalities and
skills in mind, I just
kind of wrote this.
And then I started seeing
the picture.
And then Robyn Goodman,
the producer, was
like, that's great.
You should make a music
video out of that.
And then I kind was
like, yeah.
And I put together kind of a
shot list of, yeah, it could
be this and this and
this and this.
And there was a green screen
upstairs, and I was like, we
could use a green screen.
And then one thing after
another, and I brought
everybody up into my dressing
room with my little mic, which
I do those Excedrin
things on, and had
everyone record into them.
And then that was it.
I had done something similar a
couple years ago with "The
Importance of Being Earnest." I
did a parody of the "Jersey
Shore Gone Wilde" videos which
went viral, which was great.
And I love that.
I mean, it's just an idea that
pops in my head and like, eh,
here you go.
And they were all great for
doing it, and they're all
brilliant in it.
It's very hard to get people on
board with something like
that, because you have an idea,
but it's going to take
you too long to try
and explain it.
So you just have to trust.
I said to Harriet in that first
shot when she's in the
hallway and she's running, I was
like, all you need to know
is you're regal and
you're walking.
That's it, and then
she does the rest.
And we did like one take,
and we're like, OK.
That's it.
Yup, OK.
And I was editing it during
the show when I was
backstage on iMovie.
So yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Well, I think
we're getting kicked out.
We're going to lose the room,
so we have to wrap up.
Gosh, guys, thank you
so much for coming.
MARLA MINDELLE: Thank you.